first congrats on the movie
let me start with that but uh i am
curious did you find that you had an
awful lot of friends that wanted to
visit you when you were filming
um yeah um there were
there was some um um but uh you know for
the most part they were
you know so supportive um and and i had
a lot of supportive friends and family
that went my side through the process
sure i'm just wondering if they're like
oh today's a lebron day what
i think i need to visit you uh
it was some friends you know that that
would have led to seen it um
a lot of it a lot of them knew um you
know i i had to work i couldn't you know
bring a lot of friends around but um you
know
i'm just messing with you yeah but yeah
it was you know
like i said they were a lot of them were
you know supportive
totally i think the most important thing
is uh did you walk away from this shoot
with the possibility of getting better
tickets to lakers games
probably not but i hope so
uh i'm still wishing for the best uh
because i would love to go to laker game
but
you know um the way everything um is
happening now
a lot of things are starting to open
back up um
and get back to you know some kind of
normal so
uh hopefully you know everything is
all right um you know by the end of this
year so
i hope you were right uh listen i love
learning about the behind the scenes
of the making of a movie what do you
think might surprise people to learn
about the making
of this space jam how natural
it was for everybody on set um the
chemistry
um it was really great uh and then you
know
seeing how we were communicating with
the looney tunes um how crazy that was
and you know a lot of it was just
cardboard um
pictures and you know just sticks that
we had to go off of
um and then you know doing all this um
on set and then seeing the final product
was
it was mind-blowing yeah the thing for
me is i just couldn't believe some of
the characters in the background and
those big basketball scenes
what were some of the warner brothers
characters that ended up in the movie
that you were like i cannot believe
they're back there
all of them uh there were so many
you know uh easter eggs and you know
characters that they had
um that you know you wouldn't think that
they're bringing it back
um there were a little bit of every one
of those films
that you can think of in there to be
honest
yeah i couldn't believe that i saw the
penguin from batman returns
yeah it was every the penguin from
batman returns
uh the ice monster from game of thrones
uh pennywise
uh it the dancing clown uh
man yeah there's a lot yeah i'm looking
forward to actually hitting pause on
some of those scenes to see what
what the animators put in that maybe no
one realized they put in
you know stuff like that but listen
another thing before i run out of time
uh you booked that just beyond series
and and i'm just curious what can you
tease people about that what are you
looking forward to
with with that that one is also you know
another
heartfelt one of the heartfelt stories
too um that
you know i think people are a lot of
people are gonna love um can't wait till
it comes out
it's not really much i can say about it
but it does come out uh you know
october and november so look out for
that
got it i gotta stop there i'm just gonna
say congrats on the movie i hope it's a
huge hit for you
thank you